Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2192.
David, here is another viewer who has a parent
that they are struggling with when it comes
to politics and media.
But this is a little bit of a different problem
than one we've heard before.
Take a listen to this.
Speaker 5: David.
I know you get these calls all the time.
Yeah.
How do I get my mother from Fox News?
I mean, she's not so radical that she believes
in Q and A and and all this other crazy crap.
But I can't get her to turn on Fox News.
It's think it's just insane.
And, I mean, as soon as I leave the house,
she turns this on.
I mean, anyway, I try to point out to her,
you know, how wrong they are.
And then, you know, things happen.
I go, remember I told you they were wrong
about that.
And, you know, and I told her, I said, See,
I'm right, about 90% of stuff and Fox News
is wrong about 90% of stuff, but I can't get
her to turn it off.
Yeah.
Anyway, thanks, man.
You do a great job.
Speaker 1: Thank you.
Well, so, listen, this this is tough, persistent
FOX News.
Watching can be a hard habit to break or a
hard addiction to break.
One of the things I would suggest, because
it sounds like your mom is really pretty deep
into it instead of immediately trying to get
her off of Fox.
What I would suggest is just that she diversify
the media diet.
Oftentimes with these situations, you want
to take the path of least resistance.
And the path of least resistance initially
might be saying, hey, don't go after her and
say, never watch Fox News again.
But it might be add this or that to your media
diet.
Check out the PBS NewsHour or maybe watch.
You know what?
Get more variety in your media diet.
Maybe read something would be an interesting
one as well, though not everybody reads.
Consider that the first step.
And you know, think about it like someone
who's addicted to I don't imagine someone
every morning has one of those sugary toaster
strudel.
I don't even know if those are around.
But I remember when I was a kid that was like
the epitome or like a pop tart or something.
Okay.
And please, if you work for those companies,
don't sue me.
I'm just saying they have a lot of sugar.
Imagine someone every single day has a toaster
strudel with extra powdered sugar and maple
sirup and all this stuff.
And it's like, okay, that's really bad.
But if we just go in and we say, Just stop,
just stop cold turkey, no more toaster studios.
You can understand how it would be very difficult
to get that person to say, okay, sure, no
more Toaster Studios.
What do they replace it with?
So if that was what I was dealing with, I
might first go in and go, Hey, you know what?
It might be interesting just for diversity,
you know, to try different things.
If one morning a week instead of the toaster
strudel, you instead get a piece of beautiful
multigrain toast and then spread some avocado
on it with some spicy chili oil.
Oh, okay.
Well, now we've got an alternative.
You're not saying drop the toaster strudel.
You're saying have six toaster strudel a week
and have one piece of avocado toast.
And then if that goes, okay, you go, hey,
you know what?
There's so many great breakfasts.
What if one morning you had a bowl of Greek
yogurt with sliced up berries and a no sugar
granola?
It's delicious.
So now you've got five, two, and then later
you can go, hey, you know, how are you feeling,
by the way?
You you feeling any better now that you're
introducing some other and you get the point?
Okay.
So this is the same thing I would suggest
with Fox News.
I would say, hey, you know, there's so many
different media outlets out there.
Variety is good.
What if one morning you listen to NPR's Fresh
Air instead of watching Fox and Friends or
whatever the case may be, start there and
then see where that gets you.
And you know, it's an uphill battle for sure,
but that's probably what would someone who's
really addicted, that's probably where I would
start.
We have a fantastic bonus show for you today.
As I mentioned earlier, a judge has dismissed
Mike pillows countersuits against Smartmatic
and Dominion voting machine manufacturers.
And we are going to talk about what's going
on.
Pillow is also being asked to pay Smartmatic
attorney's fees, which is just beautiful.
Republicans are vowing to kill the domestic
terrorism bill currently being discussed in
the Senate.
Why?
I'll tell you.
And an archbishop of the Catholic Church is
barring Nancy Pelosi from receiving communion
because of her support for abortion rights.
We've talked before about Catholic elected
officials and abortion and communion in the
context of Joe Biden.
We will also talk about it today in the context
of Nancy Pelosi.
Get instant access and I do mean instant by
signing up for the bonus show at join pack
mint.com.
Speaker 3: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Thank you, Alex.
And also, if you would like a discount off
of the cost of a membership, get on my newsletter
at David Pakman dot com.
You will thus get an email on Monday Memorial
Day telling you how to take advantage of a
beautiful membership discount.
See you then.
Or tomorrow.